je crois que cette décision fait partie
d'une diplomatie à la légère vu
l'ampleur de la question quand vous
savez j'ai les halles m
une place très importante dans la
mémoire juive d'enlever que juive mais
en même temps aujourd'hui dire qu'on va
transférer l'ambassade des états unis à
jérusalem c'est une décision qui depuis
1995 est reporté tous les six mois par
tous les présidents américains et
aujourd'hui le problème c'est aussi
qu'en france le crif et le consistoire
ont appelé monsieur macron à prendre la
même décision
moi oui selon vous pourquoi donald trump
a pris sa décision pourquoi il le fait
ce sont des raisons avant tout
électorale n'était pas forcément
diplomatique
écoutez d'abord son gendre on sait qu'il
est qu'il est quand même assez investi
dans cette question on aurait pensé que
caen
disons pour pouvoir faire avancer les la
question du conflit israélo-palestinien
et c'est ce qu'il fait paraît-il son
gendre il en tombera pas pourquoi il a
pris cette décision mais en même temps
on peut dire que son électorat était
d'angélique s'éteint c'est un lobby très
important cela doit s'ajouter aussi le
lobby pro israélien
mais en tout cas c'est surtout le lobby
évangélique qui depuis toujours attache
une très grande importance à la question
j'ai les élèves la masia d'appeler à
l'intifada il ya eu
là depuis quelques heures quelques
affrontements des affrontements à
bethléem est ce qu'on peut craindre un
embrasement de la situation
écoutez je ne suis pas devin d'abord je
n'en sais rien en tout cas c'est une
décision lourde de conséquence moi je
défends depuis toujours l'une des deux
étages et je m'investis beaucoup je
tiens israël et je tiens à la fondation
de l'état et palestiniens et aujourd'hui
cette décision met aussi en péril
israël parce que on ne sait pas de quoi
sera fait demain et qu'il peut y avoir
non seulement un embrasement
mais vu la situation actuellement des
différents vins les déclarations des
différents pays y compris de l'allemagne
c'est rare il peut y avoir quand même
des vrais problèmes d'aléa question que
peut faire la france que va faire la
france demain au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies je ne sais pas c'est le
mot grand doit jouer la france a un rôle
d'apaisement il ya d'une sorte de statu
quo pour le moment parce qu'aujourd'hui
dire que jérusalem va devenir la
capitale de l'état d'israël signifie
qu'il n'y aura pas de paix puisque les
palestiniens demandent aussi que ce soit
la capitale disons-le or dans une sorte
d'accommodement de deux états que la
ville reste neutre ou elle soit la ville
des deux états enfin il ya peu plein
d'autres solutions
qui existent mais là c'est couper court
à tous les
disons les pourparlers sur je veux la
paix